ARUN NAGARAJAN: Hello, and
welcome to Google Developers
Live.
This is Google Apps Unscripted.
And my name's Arun Nagarajan.
ERIC KOLEDA: And
I'm Eric Koleda.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Great.
We're live from New York.
And it's actually
one of the earliest
we've had our Google
Developers Live episode.
And it feels pretty early here.
Hopefully the folks
in Europe and Asia,
you can finally watch
it without having
to wake up in the
middle of the night.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, we're trying
to accommodate all people
from all parts and
all time zones.
ARUN NAGARAJAN:
Excellent, and so
the folks that are not
familiar with the series,
this is our monthly
series that we run,
where we walk through
our most recent launches,
talk about some of the recent
news in the app script world,
and most importantly
take your questions.
So we have a Google
Moderator page
where you can post
your questions
and vote up on other questions
that people have already asked.
And we highly encourage
you to engage with us
in that mechanism, a great way
for you to ask us questions,
put us on the spot, and try to
get the answers that you want.
But it's also really important
that if there's already
question that's there,
please vote up on those.
ERIC KOLEDA: Well, and
you can join live too.
Let's not forget.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
ERIC KOLEDA: The live part
of Google Developers Live
is there.
You can join if you go to the
Events page that hosts this
on developers.google.com/live,
find this event.
You can click to
join a live hang out
where later on in the episode,
you can ask us questions,
just like you would in the
moderator, but with a bit more
back and forth.
ARUN NAGARAJAN:
Precisely, exactly.
So we have a few
interesting launches
that we want to
talk about first.
And then we'll go into that the
Hangout and answer questions
as well.
The very first one is something
that I'm pretty excited about.
I've been working on
this for a few weeks now.
This is the Google
plug-in for Eclipse
support for Apps
Script, so the ability
to bring in your
Apps Script code
into the Google
plug-in for Eclipse,
that we've had out for a while.
The version of the
plug-in, I believe,
is 3.4, if I remember
exactly right.
And you'll be able to add
in an Apps Script project
and have multiple
projects in a workspace.
So if you can go to the computer
and take a look at the blog
posts, we talked about there.
We show you a few screenshots
of what this may look like.
And the whole idea
is that you're
able to bring your Apps
Script projects down
into your local file
system and edit it locally.
If you're someone that taking
a train to work every day
and you want to get that
extra 30 minutes of work done
on Apps Script, you
can do that now.
Now we have
auto-complete built in.
I know, Eric, that's you.
ERIC KOLEDA: That's me.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: And
in fact, we were
speaking with a few folks that
really enjoyed doing that.
And doing the testing
process, we actually
made some fixes to
improve the performance
in offline scenarios in
the disconnected state.
So that's why I bring
that up explicitly.
But the process is actually
really straightforward.
So if you already have
an Eclipse installation,
we recommend that you have the
JavaScript development tools.
But from there on, it's really
a straightforward process
to just go to the
Install New Software
and be able to pull down
the plug-in, the new version
of that.
Did I get the right version?
ERIC KOLEDA: I doesn't
list the version.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: It
doesn't list the version.
So maybe in the documentation
page you'll see it.
But it's really
straight-forward.
The great thing about this is
that it's built on the same API
that we released I think
a couple months ago,
the import/export API.
So this is the API
that allows you
to get at the source code
of your Apps Script projects
through the Drive API.
So it's a great way
for us to give you
tools using the API that
you already opened up.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah,
that's really great.
And I mean the thing
is, this is kind
of one implementation
on top of the API.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
ERIC KOLEDA: Now that doesn't
stop if someone else wants
to build their own
Eclipse integration,
or integration with a different
text editor of some kind,
or IDE.
You can use the same
functionality that we have.
There's no magic in
what we've built.
And you can go build your own.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
And in fact, a
couple of ISVs have.
One of them is called
the Edity, that's
by company name
Floreysoft, I believe.
And they've done
a really good job.
So if we can take a look
at the computer here.
They've done a really good
job of building a tool.
And there's the
Plus post where they
talk about this launch, where
the Apps Script code comes
into another
browser-based editor.
And if there are things about
that editor that you like,
maybe integrate with
the other web projects.
Maybe it's something that you
prefer the color schemes of.
You can go ahead and build
your Apps Script apps
through this new editor, Edity,
I believe it's pronounced.
And there it is on the screen.
And there's yet another
one called a Neutron Drive.
And they've also added
in Apps Script support.
And this is based
on the Drive API
that I mentioned as
well-- and again,
really straightforward to bring
in your Apps Script projects
from your Drive into other
editors, Eclipse plus these two
others that we mentioned.
And we encourage you to
go off and try these out.
But also if there are specific
capabilities that are not
met by these tools, all
the documentation is there.
So you should be able to
feel free to build your own.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah,
that's a good point.
So definitely something else
we're looking for feedback
specifically around Eclipse
as well as import/export
is is there more you need?
So there's some
known limitations
about the Eclipse
integration today.
You can edit code.
That means like download, make
modifications, and save it back
to the web.
But today, it is limited
where you can't actually
do a run through Eclipse,
or look at the logs,
or do debugging.
So we know that there are some
important functionality that's
still missing.
So start using these different
types of integrations and see,
does it meet your
needs how they are?
Is there more that
we need to do?
And is there actually more value
in having these other editors
built into our system?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
That's right.
And one of the things
that I know I miss a lot
is the ability to not get at
your container bound scripts.
Today the Drive API
only exposes the scripts
at the top level,
so the ones that you
author from script.google.com.
I know I personally would
like to see that fixed.
So we're always pushing
for those improvements.
But yes, so certainly
take a look at these.
I think it's a great
way to do things
like source control integration.
So if nothing else,
the Eclipse integration
allows you to replicate
the scripts locally.
And you can tie it into Git or
other version control systems
that you may have in order to
work with back end integrations
that you may already have
for builds and all the things
that you do.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, very good.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: So Eric,
there's another big launch
that we had recently.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, another
one of our launches
was around Form App which
is our service within Apps
Script allows you to retrieve
and modify your Google Forms.
Now this is tying into
the form editing process,
not the form
filling out process.
And what we did is there's
a couple features that
launched in the actual Google
Forms product that didn't quite
make it into our
service on day one.
And so now we have
those available to you.
And so you can see
here what they are.
One of them is the
ability to embed a YouTube
video within a form.
A lot of people what
to have instructions
or other sort of content
within their form.
Now you can programmatically add
YouTube videos to your forms.
Likewise, there's
a progress bar.
This is a nice one, especially.
I know when I'm about to fill
out a survey or feedback form,
if I get a sense that this is
going to be a two-hour process,
I might bail out.
But if I can tell
that it's only going
to take me a couple
more clicks, I
may continue on
with the process.
I think that can be an
extra little incentive
to have people as they go get
a feeling for how much they've
completed the form.
And then I think the
last one is setting
a custom closed form message.
So you may want to have a
form open for a certain amount
of time to get feedback.
But then when a
certain amount of time
has passed, a day, a
week, whatever it is,
you want to close that form
down for new responses.
And by default,
it would just say,
this form is closed or some sort
of standard Google language.
Now, however, you can set your
own custom form close message,
something like, please call
us, or wait till next month
when we'll open up again,
something like that.
So you can now do that,
once again, programmatically
via the Form App.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah and the
example in the blog post,
I think, is a really simple
one to get started with.
I think you can literally
copy and paste it.
And it will build you a form
and highlight all the new APIs
that we added.
ERIC KOLEDA: That's
a good point.
This is the full code.
There's not just
a small snippet.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: I think I was
doing a demo recently where
I was able to just
copy and paste it.
And it was a great
way to demonstrate
what Form App is all about,
along with the new capabilities
that we added.
My particular favorite is the
custom form closed message.
I think that really does give
a bit more polish to your form.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: And if you're
a T-shirt ordering process,
you can say, all
mediums are taken
or this process is now closed.
Email us directly for additional
detail, something like that.
It's a much, much
more user friendly,
than putting a generic
message out there.
ERIC KOLEDA: Oh
yeah, definitely.
I mean [INAUDIBLE] next
actions, like actions
that you could follow up on,
rather than just say, hey,
we're sorry, closed
for business.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: And I know
the teacher and the education
community are really excited
about the video capabilities.
So if you have like
a Khan Academy video
followed by couple
of quiz questions,
something that would
be really cool.
ERIC KOLEDA: That's really nice.
ARUN NAGARAJAN:
Yeah, so you could
build some interesting
scripts around that,
automate that script
building flow.
And we're looking
forward to seeing
what you can build with that.
ERIC KOLEDA: Cool.
ARUN NAGARAJAN:
Speaking of demos,
one of the things that I
recently was involved with
was a Hangout on Air with
the Google Enterprise team.
So Apps Script,
as you know, works
on any account,
any Google account,
but if you're running
within an enterprise,
there's some additional
nice things about it
where you can have your
script run within just
the organization.
You can restrict access to
who gets the web app URL.
You can also, as an admin,
do interesting things
around user manager and
domain APIs that we have.
So there's always been a really
nice fit in the enterprise
space with Apps Script.
And recently I did
a Hangout on Air,
which is sort of their
equivalent of Google Developers
Live, mostly meant for end
users to come and learn
about something new in the
Google Apps and API space.
And it was fun.
It was about 30 minutes.
And that is was
more introductory
than maybe some of you
guys are already used to,
but definitely check it out.
It's a quick, 20,
30 minute video.
And if you're ever
looking for something
to get started with Apps Script,
or talk about use cases, what
are some of the enterprise
ideas that we would like
to see implemented, and
we're seeing around the world
partners and customers already
do, this Hangout on Air
talks about that.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
I think Apps Script is a
great general purpose tool.
But there are a lot
of specific segments.
We mentioned education
and enterprise,
where we have either
certain technologies,
certain capabilities, or just
certain kind of techniques
and applications--
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
ERIC KOLEDA: --that
we'd love to discuss
if you guys are interested.
ARUN NAGARAJAN:
Definitely, definitely.
And I think the ideas
are really where
I think a lot of cool
things come from.
And we often see a script.
Maybe it's 100 lines
of code, but the way
it solves a particular
problem is really
where the value of
Apps Script comes
in, rather than the complexity
of the coolness of the code,
which in some platforms,
it's fun to look at code
and be like, hey, this
is so complicated.
But in Apps Script, it's about
the work flow and the use case
more so than the code.
ERIC KOLEDA: That's
a good point.
I mean, I know Apps Script
pretty much inside and out.
But I see people do things
that I never even imagined.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Right.
ERIC KOLEDA: Because they
come with a set of problems,
and a set of creativity, and
ideas around a solution space.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Right.
ERIC KOLEDA: You're right.
That's where the interest is.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Awesome.
So do we have anyone on
the Hangout at this point?
We have a new name there.
I'm not sure if you're if
you're familiar with Jasper.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah,
I know Jasper.
Jasper, can you hear us?
And would you like
to ask a question?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: OK.
ERIC KOLEDA: All right.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Well, if
you have any questions,
feel free to chime in.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah we're
going to leave the mics open.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
ERIC KOLEDA: All
right, in the meantime,
we do have some questions
on our Google Moderator.
People have been
diligently posting.
So let's start
with one of those.
Right here at the
top-- are there
plans to add GAS capabilities
to drawings and presentations?
And by GAS, I think they
mean Google Apps Script.
ARUN NAGARAJAN:
Yeah, it's something
that we've been looking
into-- no official plans
at this point.
The idea of Apps
Script is to first
of all really rock the Google
Docs, Google Spreadsheets,
and Google Forms
experience right now.
We are very much
focused on that.
And certainly spreadsheets
and other tools
are right in that
suite of capabilities,
but at this point, there's no
plans that we have announced.
ERIC KOLEDA:
Gotcha, sounds good.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Actually
let me just throw in--
so there's already a feature
enhancement in our issue
tracker.
Please go find it
and include details
on what you want to build, what
are some of the capabilities
that you're looking for.
I know with slides, the
most common scenario
is I want to auto create 15
slides from a few bullets.
So if that's what it is,
please put a vote in,
as much details as you can.
It really helps us
prioritize things.
ERIC KOLEDA: That's
a good point.
Our product manager,
when he's trying
to decide what's
the next thing we
should do, where should we
put our energy, if there's
a whole bunch of
really compelling use
cases around drawings
or presentations,
that definitely
helps us as a team.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: And really the
Google plug-in for Eclipse,
a lot of people wanted
offline access to their code.
A lot of people wanted custom
source control integration
with their code.
And one approach we
took was expose the API
and then give you the
plug-in for Eclipse.
But we do look at
this and nothing
is out of the realm
of possibilities
with good use cases
and good details.
ERIC KOLEDA: It's true.
All right, so the next
one here is about SAP.
SAP is the leader in
enterprise workflow management.
Do you see Google Apps
Script with Google Apps
for Business tools
becoming a true business
platform for ERPs and SMEs?
That is just
chock-full of acronyms.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah, yeah,
yeah, so SMEs, I think,
is small to medium enterprises.
So and Google Apps has been
very successful in this space,
in the small to medium
enterprises, I think.
Either $50 a user or
$60 a user, whatever
the rate is, it's really easy
to get started, very powerful.
And with Apps Script, you
have this additional layer
for permeability on top of it.
However, we're not
product people.
I know our job is to support
the APIs and capabilities.
ERIC KOLEDA: And developers.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: And
developers, exactly.
And so we don't
really have a comment
on whether it's going to replace
one product or another product.
It's truly up to you as
to what you can build
and what problems
you're solving.
So unfortunately, we
would like to think
it's solving every
problem in the world.
But it's up to the
developers and our partners
on what they build and
what problems to solve.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, that's
a really good point.
I mean, we also do focus a lot
on the ability to integrate.
So we want to make sure that
if there are popular tools
out there that we have the
integration points via URL
fetching or other
sorts of technologies
that you can do to access
those outside systems,
bring the data, push data out.
We want to make it
so that there's not
a lot of friction in getting
done what you need to get done,
but not really commenting
on specific technologies.
All right, great.
The next question
we have here is,
Is Google Apps
Script a good tool
for a web app in
the marketplace?
Can it handle 500-plus users?
Fausto here has
put a lot of energy
into his Shared
Contacts app and would
like to make sure it can scale.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Hi, Fausto.
I'm not sure if
you're watching live.
I know this is a
really cool tool.
I've seen the tool in action.
So a lot of time when people
talk about scalabilities
around not necessarily
Apps Script
specifically, as much as
the specific systems or back
end APIs it's using,
so in this case,
the contact service has
its set of limitations
and capabilities.
So it's really a question of can
Contact Service and the quota
that you get with it, will
that scale to 500 users?
And I think that's a
really hard question
to answer live without thinking
about what are the use cases on
is it pulling every minute?
Or is it once a day they're
checking these Shared Contacts?
In general, 500 users
don't sound like that much.
And I think it's going to
be OK, as long as you're
using so the caching and
sort of pulling every minute.
Maybe you aggregate it for all
users and do one batch call.
So there are techniques with
which you can support that.
But I don't know if you
have any comments on this.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, I think
this question is probably
in response to the
next question, which
is how he is experiencing--
I've been working with him
a lot over the issue tracker--
some occasional timeout
problems with regards
to calls to the contacts
service, the Google
Contacts API.
And so I think in this case,
you found a bottleneck.
All the parts of
the code perhaps
are functioning well
and scaling well.
And there's one bottleneck
around the contacts API.
There is something strange
going on in regards
to how it works sometimes
when you run it manually,
but not on automative process.
And it has something
to do, without getting
too much into it, into
how these kind of requests
flow through our back
ends at different times.
So yeah, you did
find a bottleneck.
And I think if you were to
scale this up to 500,000 users,
you'd find other
bottlenecks as well.
I think part of what we're
trying to do on our team
is to help identify what
those bottlenecks are and see
if we can't get them
out of your way.
But that said, I think
there is eventually
an upper bound to
when it makes sense
to no longer be using Apps
Script for a certain task.
Obviously, you wouldn't
want to run a brand
new social platform
on Apps Script.
For millions and
millions of users,
it's just not the
right tool for the job.
But I think 500 users sounds
like it's a reasonable.
I think it fits what
Apps Script aims to be.
And I think we'll
keep working with you
on the specific problem and
hopefully get it resolved.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: It's a very
complicated problem to debug.
So we're certainly aware of
the issues that you're facing
and we're trying to do our best.
When you think
about Apps Script,
so Google Contacts has had
an API for a long time.
And what we're trying
to do is just wrap
that in this really
nice JavaScript API
and offer that to you.
So a lot of times
the problem might
be in the back end API itself
or in our implementation
of the wrapper
logic, or somewhere
in your code in the way
things have sequenced.
There's a lot of
different moving parts.
In general, web apps, few
hundred users, no problem,
specific bottlenecks, we have
to dig in and figure out.
Similar issues might
have with spreadsheets.
So if you're serving the
same spreadsheet for hundreds
of users, depending
on what you're
doing with that
spreadsheet, there
might be some
issues-- so certainly
something that we need to dig
in and do some debugging on.
ERIC KOLEDA: All right,
I think there's only
one more question we have
here in the moderator,
and it's about
Google Maps and not
related to Apps
Script whatsoever.
So I think we'll just
bypass that one for now.
But you can we reach
out to the Google Maps
team for specific
questions about their APIs
and the products there.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: And I think they
have a Google Developers Live
series as well.
So it might be
developers.google.com/live/maps.
ERIC KOLEDA: That
sounds about right.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: All right.
ERIC KOLEDA: And
yeah, maybe this
was just a matter of
turning to the wrong channel
at the wrong time.
But hopefully you can get
your question answer there.
I believe that's it
for our moderator.
Let's just check back
in on the live Hangout.
I see we have some people there.
Does anybody have a question
they'd like to ask live?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Or a comment.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
Tell us what you've been
building with Apps Script
recently.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Well, there's
one other announcement
that I want to make.
I forgot to mention earlier.
ERIC KOLEDA: Surprise
announcement.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: It's not really
that surprising, I guess.
So I'm going to actually be
doing a Google Developers group
presentation to the group
in London this Friday.
I think it's part of
their Dev Fest programs.
So I'll be joining
in via Hangout,
using our great technology to
present remotely for the folks
in the UK.
If you're in the
area, definitely go.
I forget the exact offices
where they are in London.
But check them out.
The GDG London group
is running this,
so looking forward
to presenting to you
and giving you some
background on Apps Script.
ERIC KOLEDA: It's great.
Now have you presented at
other groups in the past?
ARUN NAGARAJAN:
Yeah, so I presented
to the group in Bogota
in Columbia remotely.
And it's a lot of fun
to present remotely.
And sometimes I get
really good questions,
even though I feel
like I can't see them.
And the technology
works really well.
And it's a great
way for us to not
have to travel out
everywhere but also provide
any content and demos that
we can to get the group
to think about Apps Script and
build some interesting things.
I'm trying to present
as many as possible
and also more importantly
find local authorities,
local experts, that
they can take on.
So my goal for representing
the Google Developers
group in London is to
find folks in London that
can deliver that
same presentation
and become a local
expert for us.
ERIC KOLEDA: That's great.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: So if you're
interested in running Dev Fest
sessions, let us know.
And we'll put in touch with you
with the local GDG folks that
can help you organize,
polish your content.
And of course, we're here to
help you with any presentation
ideas or any set
of slides as well.
ERIC KOLEDA: There's
a lot of great perks
too as you get
involved in Dev Fest,
or maybe even if you can
graduate into our Developer
Expert program.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
ERIC KOLEDA:
There's really a lot
of capabilities to get
involved with Google more.
There's giving talks, lots
of other great benefit.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
So the program is called
Google Developers Expert.
So developers.google.com/expert,
I think is the URL.
And if you go there,
you can find out all
about this program.
So that's sort of the
top tier of involvement
with Google Developer
technologies.
It certainly takes a while
to get to that point,
but we recommend that if you
are really passionate about Apps
Script, let us
know first of all.
And let us know
about your projects,
and let us know about your talks
or blog posts on Apps Script.
And we'll keep monitoring it and
nominate you for this process,
if that makes sense.
But the perks are huge.
Maybe it starts with just
a t-shirt here there.
But it could graduate up
to visits up to the Google
offices, direct channel
to Google engineers to us,
and a lot of really
interesting things
that if you are passionate about
a particular Google technology,
it's a great way
to get recognized
and get benefits from it.
ERIC KOLEDA: I remember at I/O
last year just how much power
even just a t-shirt had.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
That's right.
ERIC KOLEDA: T-shirts
are very powerful.
But it goes so far beyond that.
So yeah, definitely
we're looking
to recruit more folks into
our Apps Script world,
get them excited, spread
the good news to everybody.
But I don't know
about you, Arun,
but I feel like Apps
Script has so much power
and is still pretty unknown
to a majority of developers.
ARUN NAGARAJAN:
That's right, yeah.
It's often times, and
I give presentations,
and everybody knows about
Gmail, and Docs, and drive.
And there's probably
about 10%, 15%
of the room that has
heard of Apps Script,
and even small percentage
that has actually tried out
even our simple five
minute quick starts.
So you get help us
spread the message
and get more people to
at least try it out,
see if it's right for them.
ERIC KOLEDA: That's great.
All right, well, I'm going
to give one more crack
at the people live
in the Hangout.
This is your last chance to
ask a question to two Google
engineers.
All right, going,
going, gone-- I
think that does it for
today's episode, Arun.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: All
right, thank you
very much for anyone
who joined live
and for the questions they
were asked on moderator.
And I think we already scheduled
the next one, I forget.
But we'll be doing
this again in November.
And I think it will be deep
into the winter by then.
So talk to you guys then.
ERIC KOLEDA: Thank you, goodbye.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: See you.